what's up believe me and welcome to
another AMA we've got half an hour
together I want to answer your questions
provide as much your value as possible
I missed you last week I think maybe two
weeks I had daddy daddy camp my son was
home for the summer and I decided to
prioritize him over other things and now
I'm back so let's do it we got 30
minutes together I want to bring you as
much value as possible
give me your questions put it in the
live chat picking us off to start is
Salima how do you know if you have too
many unrealistic priorities so for me
unrealistic is an interesting word I use
that as a positive
I like having something unrealistic I
think having a business that I'm trying
to build the trying to solve the world's
biggest problem is completely
unrealistic it's never gonna happen a
lot of people see that as a use the word
unrealistic as a negative connotations
like that's them we're gonna happen and
so they give up and they quit I like it
so I'm not quite sure where you're
coming from with unrealistic but that
being said if I'm if I'm looking at my
calendar like if I'm you here's what I
do I've got all these priorities I got
there's all these lists of things that I
want to do am i making progress on them
or in a regular basis like these things
that are unrealistic for you is slowly
is that starting to happen and if it is
and keep going and if it's not then you
have to change something so how I look
at it is is a perfect example I'm trying
to I'm trying to solve the world's a
girl's problem it's never gonna be
solved I'm trying to make progress every
day and the way that I measure that is
through the work that I'm doing so the
YouTube videos that I make right I make
three videos a day they have an impact I
see the comments I see the results right
it's shifting people slowly right it's
not the how many billions of people that
are in the world all watching together
but it's having an impact one video at a
time on the people who are watching why
do I move to ig why am i spending so
much time on IG recently why am i
posting six times a day
why don't go live on IG four times a
week and YouTube only one time a week
because on IG I could bring people in IG
Instagram just you don't know I like
being able to bring people in live
picture-in-picture
and be able to help them with their
problems I prefer that for I don't know
why YouTube doesn't let me
bringing people on video to help honor
one that would be awesome but because
they don't I spend more time on IG going
live than I do here when my son was at
summer camp my son was off summer camp
for the past two weeks I prioritize
spending time with him over everything
else
so I was on business superlight mode I
was still answering emails though still
responding to some social but I didn't
book a single meeting I didn't do live
streams on YouTube I didn't do I did
maybe one live stream total on Instagram
everything was super light mode because
I wanted to spend time with my son and
so we took him to the theme parks we did
movies we built stuff at home we played
League of Legends we did a whole bunch
of different fun stuff and I don't
regret that and so understanding what
your priorities are and then making sure
that your calendar your calendar
represents your actions right it
represents what your be gonna be doing
every day
if you put something in your calendar
and you don't do that thing that's a
different problem but your calendar
represents what you should be doing on a
daily basis what I like to do is I think
about it is if I did these things during
the week will it help me accomplish my
goals I'm trying to solve the world's
greatest problem or I'm trying to be a
better dad or I'm trying to whatever the
thing is and I'm trying to do look at
your calendar if I did these things on
these days like I plan to will I make
progress towards my goals and if I will
then I keep doing it if I don't then I
cut it and that's it I think that's
that's how to do it I think it's great
to have a forever ambition a forever
goal that will never be realized and
then what you're doing right now and I
don't have a lot of in-between I don't
have a five-year goal I think if you set
five-year goals for yourself then you're
thinking too small because you don't
know what you're capable of doing in
five years okay next
how would you generate cash quickly so
you can build a brand business slowly
how would you generate cash quickly so
you can build a brand business slowly I
would look at doing something in the
industry that I'm trying to get into so
as an example if I wanted to be youtuber
honestly if I wanted to be a youtuber
and I didn't know what I was doing yet I
was early startup stages I would make my
youtube business my side hustle and I
would go try to learn from somebody
who's an expert in it so
actually try to get a job working for a
youtuber and I try to learn the ins and
outs I'd get paid to make mistakes like
beginning paid to make contacts and to
learn how the industry works whether I'm
in that job for three months six months
a year I'm learning while I'm getting
paid all the meantime working on my
business on the side
evenings weekends every single day I'm
making videos I'm making comments I'm
being involved in my community so you
get the best of both worlds what am i
moving my side business is making enough
money for me to quit then I quit and I'm
looking in that side business for you
know even at a time right you're doing
in evenings and weekends so I find what
is the thing that I can bring the most
value to so if I was looking at doing it
myself starting all over again if I had
some job working for a youtuber and I
wanted to be the nice big youtuber what
is the one thing I have lots of ideas I
have my mission and trying to solve the
world's biggest problem I may have lots
of ideas so a different series that I
want to pump out what would be the one
thing what is one series that I'm gonna
commit to and launch and make it as
great as possible the one thing and so I
would probably start with the top ten
series I would probably start making one
top ten series a week or if I could do
more than one a week awesome and start
putting that out and so it seems like
you're just taking this tiny little bite
because you have this huge ambition of
what you want to do but it's the bite
that can open up the gates for you it's
the bite that if you get some progress
and in momentum on then it opens up
everything else and allows you to quit
your job and go full-time we never even
be the biggest part it's your step but
what I hate doing is something totally
irrelevant I hate the idea of spending
your time doing something that you hate
just trying to make money to then
support the thing that you want to do
spend your time in the industry that you
want to work in so one get a job working
for someone who's doing it and to find
the fastest path to providing value
making making progress inside the
industry that you want to be in not
trying to do something totally different
alright guys lots of questions coming in
if you if you tagged me it's a lot
easier for me to see the questions than
just the the
so let me go to something here me LaVon
Evan marriage and business how that's a
that's an ongoing struggle you know it's
it's part of the process you know like
I've got Nina here I've got my son here
I think first off you need to define
what an ideal relationship looks like
for you you know for me I love Nina it's
amazing I also love my work and I also
love my son and I want to spend time
doing all of it I I wouldn't be happy
spending 24 hours a day just cuddling
with Nina you know like I need I need to
do more and if I wouldn't be happy
either like you need to do more and so
what does your ideal schedule look like
I have a couple ideas on here one I
would say you need to make your time
count I think so much of what you say
you're spending time in your marriage
you're not actually checked in you're
you're watching a movie or you're
sitting on the couch and you're on your
phone and you're not actually having a
real conversation or spending quality
time with your wife or your husband or
the other people in your life it's not
it you look at your Cal and you're like
hey I'm spending 18 hours a week with
with my wife but how many of those are
actually quality hours not a lot so at
first do an audit of the actual time
you're spending because if you had even
an hour a day of super quality time like
that may be enough that may be all you
need as opposed to the 3-4 hours of
garbage time when you're really checked
out doing something else - I would try
to involve your spouse in what you're
doing either in the business itself if
you can manage working together but if
not then just understanding what is
happening in your business so that is so
that is your thing combined not just
your thing alone and this was really
hard for me because I don't share I
don't need to share anything I don't
need to share anything with with Nina I
don't need to tell her about my day I
don't need I don't need her support on
anything I don't need to tell her
anything it doesn't make me feel good to
tell her what happened today on this
livestream like I don't need to lots
people love to talk in the share I'm not
an overshare I don't need that
she loves to hear about what's happening
so I need to make a conscious effort
every day to talk about what I have been
doing jeremiad how my day went you know
you come home how was your day instead
of just saying yeah it was good
I need to start thinking okay what
actually happened today what was a
highlight you know I'm excited to be
back on doing YouTube lives what what is
a highlight how can I share story of it
but then as as your spouse understands
the the day-to-day of what you're doing
the day-to-day of the problems that
you're facing the day-to-day of the
excitement's of ideas that you have
coming up then if they can't support
with with their own skillset or ideas
its emotional support it's understanding
that this is something that's super
important to you and then when you feel
down they feel down not because of they
just see you feeling down but they
understand the wait they understand the
gravity and so involving your partner
either in the business or at least in
the understanding of what you're doing
in the business I think is super
critical so that your partner sees this
as an us thing even though it's you
doing it it's an us thing because he or
she is emotionally invested into it with
you as opposed to your off doing this
thing so as an example if I was to go
off and play league of legends with some
buddies that's it that's it that's a
boys night out that's Evans off going to
do that thing as opposed to the brand
Evan Carmichael the YouTube channel the
the website the books is more of an us
thing and the better job I do of
integrating Nina into the awareness of
what is happening in my business the
more she's emotionally involved and the
more she's going to support everything
that I'm doing and unless it seems like
an only thing so I think that's super
important good luck and then just
schedule like whatever it is that that
you however you need to react so for me
like I don't have a cell phone number so
that when I'm with Nina I'm with Nina
you can't reach me you can't call me
there's no way to distract me at the
time I'm sitting with her with her on
Saturday is our day of us our Saturday
is she loves new food so every Saturday
I find a new restaurant for us to go to
I booked some entertainment the mo can
be a walk in the park or a street
festival like Saturday is all about us
no no
family chores no shopping no admins
stuff no work stuff it's our day to do
our stuff because we're both typically
working a lot during the week and so
that works that works for us but find
the rhythm that works for you and had
the conversation around it okay went off
that was good I haven't talked about
that for a while
Geronimo is going to a top business
school worth it for an entrepreneur I
don't think so
not if you want to be not if you're sure
I just posted a video on my IG TV today
about I think school is a good backup
plan I think if you want to get a job
schools fantastic I think that's what
the gear you to do I think even more
than the knowledge that they teach you
in school just having a degree something
that a lot of big companies look for as
as a way to recruit and also the more
education you have the the more it looks
good the NBA the PhD especially for
certain fields you know you can't be a
doctor without going to school and so I
think if you know you want a corporate
path you have to go to school I think if
you are not sure if you want a corporate
path or not then I think you should
still go to school because you have it
as a back-up plan
but I think if you know that you don't
want to be in the corporate path you
know absolutely in every fiber of your
being that you want to be an
entrepreneur I don't think school does
much for you I think I think you're
honestly wasting years of your life for
me I would have still gone back to
school I went to University of Toronto
it's considered the best university in
in my country of Canada I didn't know I
wanted to be an entrepreneur I had a
bunch of entrepreneurial tendencies I
ended up meeting the people who I became
business partners with in university and
I developed my love for I discovered
that I wanted to be an entrepreneur
through that process but I didn't know I
wasn't a hundred percent sure going in
and so I think it's a great back-up plan
they had because if you end up having to
go get a job just having a high school
diploma is not gonna put you in really
good standing that being said what one
other little hack if if you're on the
fence and you're going to go to school I
would use your school to help you as
much as possible in your business I
would be looking at can I do all those
school products that you do can you do
it around your company every school
project that I had to do my marketing
class and business class every class
that I could
did it around my company - I was able to
go talk to potential customers at my
university so the business that I was in
we also sold to academia as part of our
business model so I can go talk to
researchers our potential customers
easily because I'm a student doing a
project instead of going and selling or
doing market research from a company 3 I
looked at working with one of my
professors on designing your own course
I didn't even know this was possible
until my last year you could design your
own course at a lot of universities you
see the buying of a professor who's
gonna who's gonna mark you and you you
get you get a you get an assignments to
work on that you decide together and
they give you a grade there's no exam
there's no official process so I did one
around pricing this guy this marketing
prof was a pricing expert I said hey I
have a company I want to learn how to
price my product how about we do a joint
course around pricing for my industry he
said yeah that'd be great he used it for
his research and I got bonus mentoring
and not having to write an exam so that
was a huge hack I'd also like in
retrospect so I'm starting over now I'd
also look at using every media outlet on
campus I'd be looking at how can I use
the school radio station social media
accounts newspaper to profile my
business as a University of Toronto
entrepreneur trying to do things I'd
also be looking to tap into the alumni
network everybody who went to University
of Toronto who might want to give back
and help out helped mentor a young
entrepreneur I'd be tapping into all
those people I didn't think of these
things back then but if you are going to
go to school and it's your backup plan
then I would look at how do i hack my
entire to three four-year education
there so that I'm actually growing as an
entrepreneur as well outside of just the
material you gonna learn in the class
because that material honestly is not
gonna help you that much boom there we
go
I love it hacking hacking hacking
hacking next Anthony Evan and Bob
Proctor on my favorite Canadians all
right very cool I love it there's a lot
of us that are awesome Canadians go
Canada but Bob is a good company I
appreciate and I'm humbled by being
lumped into that category
Welton Evan what to do when you don't
know where to go so I think one of the
most common questions I get asked is
what is my purpose where am I going what
am I supposed to do I think your purpose
comes from your pain I think most people
try to avoid the pain of their past and
I think you need to run into it instead
of away from it I think just sitting in
your pain doesn't help but understanding
that when you've gone through something
painful you want to make it easier for
others I think humans are built to serve
I think I think 99.9% of humans are good
people and we want to help others and
the best way to help is through pain
that you have gone through I think it is
just human nature that when you have
gone through something negative
something painful you want to make the
path easier for the next person why I
love entrepreneurs so much because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur I
hated my life I felt the least level
lowest level of self-respect ever and I
know how painful that was and so I want
to help as much as I leave on the
optimism of solving the world's biggest
problem in entrepreneurs are gonna solve
every problem in the world I believe
that but why I really do what I do is
because I struggled so much and I want
you to not struggle as much it's still
gonna be a struggle but if I can make it
just a little bit easier I wish that I
had me you know I wish like when I was
19 get my business going I had this
YouTube channel I had this mentor to
look up to so I try to be that now so
you don't know what to do go back and
look at any struggle that you've been
through whatever the biggest pain point
of your life has been and then help
people through it and if you are if
you're if you're not through it yet then
you talk about the journey so for me I
got through the battle of
entrepreneurship I sold my business I
had success so I could talk about that
but if I was still building it and just
suffering through it right now then I
could talk about that here's what I'm
doing I don't know what I'm doing I I
hate my life right now I suck I'm trying
to build this thing up here's my next
experiment and taking people along a
journey and the journey itself is
inspiration because so many people are
so afraid to fail that they don't even
try and watching you go off and do your
thing is an inspiration seeing you take
action will inspire other people to take
action even if the thing you do doesn't
work it doesn't it's
not so much about the results is that
you got up when you were willing to try
like showing up every day is super
important if you show up every day you
won't win every day you'll have a lot of
losses you'll have a lot of showing up
and failure but if you show up every day
for the next year your life will look
totally different because you'll get
some wins and that journey is an
inspiration so you've been through it or
you are going through it sharing that is
is the path your purpose comes from your
pain good luck Bruce my parents aren't
supporting me in doing business what to
do I just put a video on my youtube
channel yesterday you know two days ago
this week it's called the coming it's
called look at the thumbnail look that
says parents suck I really recommend
looking at that I think for the most
part it's one understanding that your
parents likely love you having a little
bit of empathy for them they just want
to see you succeed and they don't think
that entrepreneurship is going to be the
path understand where they're coming
from right they love you they want you
to win their world is totally different
like the world they grew up in is
totally different than the opportunities
that you have right now in front of you
no matter how much they may think that
their generation was the change
generation and how much things evolved
and changed it's nothing compared to
what's happening right now
the idea that you could you could build
a million dollar plus business just
using this just making videos is crazy
to them it doesn't make sense and so
that's what they're afraid of they're
afraid you're gonna try this thing and
it's not gonna work and and you're not
going to be successful because that's
what they want you to be as successful
so one having MPD that's where they're
coming from if you start off yelling at
them and saying you suck you don't
support me why can't you believe in my
dream you know lose if you go on the
offense like that you're gonna lose so
understand that perspective second I
would also say a lot of times when young
people are working with their parents
you just think everything is gonna work
out right it's like you're trying to
defend why YouTube was a good idea and
you just think that it's gonna work out
it's gonna work out and that's what
they're afraid of that overconfidence in
the thing that you're trying to do is
the exact thing that they are afraid of
and so by you being even more confident
isn't gonna help the situation is gonna
make it worse
they think you're ignorant they think
you're full of blind spots they think
you're missing it and they need to be
the one to show it to you because they
love you but if you go in and say I
really need to start this YouTube thing
like there's something inside me that
says I need to try this it may not work
out you know what it probably won't work
out like most people don't break through
but I know that if I don't at least try
it then I know that I'm gonna regret
this I know that I'm gonna regret this
for the rest of my life if I don't at
least give it my shot even if it fails I
can deal with it failing but I can't
deal with not knowing and it may mean
that I end up broke and having a sleep
on than somebody's couch and I hope that
it's your couch that's a really
different message and one that's much
easier to understand then you you hate
me you suck why can't you support me
right and so just having in 99 you know
98% of the circumstances that's the
answer and it works for some of you your
parents might actually just suck and you
need to get out and do your own thing
and deal with the consequences and that
means you have to move out and maybe be
disowned by the family you know but but
that's an extreme case most cases aren't
like that
okay next Nick any suggestions for 21
year old trying to become a millionaire
preferably billionaire through music
movies TV radio etc so it depends on
your talent man it depends on what
you're good at what you're talking about
you know whether you're using YouTube TV
I don't think TVs gonna be honestly the
path but what are you good at like
having having a skill set and then
having a message I think is gonna be how
you win so let's say you're your
musician like if you're if you're a dope
musician you are like the next thing
just having the ability to sing isn't
enough there's tons of fantastic singers
it's the message in the store like you
have to be able to sing truth what what
is the truth why watch these videos
hopefully I'm speaking some truth that
resonates if not you're gonna bounce
being a great speaker isn't just about
having confidence on stage it's about
saying something that means something to
people so in your song in your art I
need to feel truth I need the
like yes that's exactly what I'm feeling
that's exactly what I'm going through
this song is saving my life I love it
right that's what you need to have come
through and then you just get to the
distribution so YouTube videos Spotify
IG TV Instagram videos DMS right I want
to get my music on every channel that
has content that relates like could you
be the background for somebody else or
could it be the theme song for
somebody's video hacking the
distribution is gonna be super important
but it but if you don't have skill if
you don't have a message it's not gonna
mean anything so good luck a cache what
do you want to say about Sandeep
Maheshwari and indeed entrepreneur a
motivational speaker I don't know him or
her so I got nothing to say but thank
you for the love Richard what does the
future look like for entrepreneurs as AI
and technology advances does it look
bleak for us I'm not too steeped into
the AI world we did a video or is just
coming up around what Elon Musk saw and
what Mark Cuban thought net I'm I'm on
Team Humanity like I think with all the
negativity that's out there I think our
lives are only getting better I think
it's only easier to win I think I think
Hugh manages gets better with every
generation and so I think we I think I
have this t-shirt I don't but it's about
a bird isn't afraid of sitting on a tree
and being afraid that the branch will
break because her trust is in her wings
not the branch I have trust in humanity
I have trust in our wings and I think
through every every evolution we're
gonna win we'll figure it out there's
enough good people in the world to make
it happen next Shannon what's the
difference from the inspiration of
motivation I don't know not something I
really think about it's more like why
why does it matter I get inspired to do
something I guess he creates it creates
if I had to define an inspiration I'm
thinking it it gives me an idea
I get inspired to do something I hadn't
thought about before and and motivation
is I know what I want to do but it's
giving me the drive and hunger
hustle to do it but why does it matter
why does it matter what the difference
inspiration motivation is that's my
question back ok next
Ahmad how do I find a mentor so two two
ways one is an in-person mentor somebody
who you meet with connect with one on
one might be an ongoing like mentorship
applies ongoing relationship I would
start by finding somebody who you look
up to in respect who you can reach and
just asking for one question don't say
hey will you be my mentor cuz that's
like saying hey will you be my kid or my
father or my mother like it's a
relationship nobody's gonna do that off
of a cold email or tweet or DM and so
ask one question right so if you're
asking me a question
Evan here's what I your how do I become
a minute how do I find a mentor right
like you ask one question and and on the
outreach pay attention like if somebody
that you look up to is going live join
in like if if you want me to be your
mentor as an example you see me going
live like be the first one every single
time ask a great question
supports a community every single time
that's how you get on somebody's radar
people are going live all the time
people are tweeting and doing IG and
doing YouTube videos all the time be
there be a part of the community be a
known quantity so that when I see your
name I recognize who you are because
you're so involved in what I'm doing
ask one question and then from that one
question do the thing whatever they're
telling you to do go out and do that
thing here's what happens so many times
they ask a question you don't do that
thing because that thing is hard because
you're scared of a door because you
don't think it's gonna work
you don't do that thing and then you
come back with a second question never
do that they don't help you again if you
come back with a second question say
well hey what happened to the first one
unless you've tried it like 182 times
and you just can't figure it out then
come back and say I really want to
figure out this one thing I tried it 182
times I can't get it to work can you
please help me again not I tried it
twice and it didn't work out so be the
person follows through that's the thing
everybody loves mentoring like mentors
love mentoring the problem is the
mentees don't do an
and so you are being lumped in with
every other mentee that that person's
had that hasn't done anything because
you're afraid to actually take the
action and do the work so don't be that
person right actually do the work so you
ask one question instead of will you be
my mentor and then you actually take
action on the thing whether you get
results or you try 182 times and you
don't get results when you follow up
again right and if you're doing the work
then you ask the second question right
you got results thank you so much here's
my second question right and it revolves
the second way to do is through what I
call aspirational mentors that's what I
do on my channel like Steve Jobs AP
Giannini they're not around anymore
right but I can learn from them and so
there's somebody who you look up to that
you may not you may not be able to find
like Howard Schultz CEO of Starbucks are
now ya not see you anymore I don't think
he's even chairman anymore anyway he
never goes live he's not on Twitter he's
like the access is ridiculous try to get
to him but I can still learn from him
right and so if there's anybody that you
look up to and you want to learn from
read their books watch their videos
listen to their interviews channels like
mine might expose you to people right
the the requests that we just had come
in right it's like I'm learning about
new people all the time every day we're
featuring different people in the
channel so you might get exposed to
somebody and if listen if you if you
come to my channel learn about in the
Veen Jane and then get obsessed with
Naveen Jane and then leave my channel
because you're learning what you need
from him awesome like go do that thing
it's great and so that's what I would be
doing as well not just the one-on-one
mentors but the aspirational mentors
that you can learn from one more
question one more question one more
question
when we got send deep is an Indian
entrepreneur motivational speaker I
already answered this question get me
into the question um but it's lots of
questions but if you don't tag me it's a
lot harder for me to see last question
okay that keen why don't you start when
did you start intermediate fast and I've
been on it for a month and I love it by
the way what's for lunch
I haven't eaten lunch yet it's uh it's
one o'clock
I started intermitted fasting I don't
remember I'm so bad looking back all
I've had today so far this is my second
giant thing of water I've got a coffee
it's not quite intimated fasting because
this is one sugar to milk so I'm a
little bit off and then the thing that
really helps is actually the salt
Himalayan pink salt helps a lot so I
don't know lunch it's one o'clock now
for me I'm solid I still to drink my
coffee still got some salt I might eat
at 3:00 I don't know I got a whole day
of interviews I've gone I might go till
5:00 I don't know we'll see when I when
I get really hungry
I'm gonna eat anyway that was a random
question ended on thank you guys to the
love I appreciate you well you still got
lots of time left today and I hope that
you make it count you know I hope that
you show up today and then you show up
tomorrow you show up the next day and
you make something that you will make
your kids proud and when you hit the
pillow tonight you say I'm proud of what
happened today I'm proud of the work
that I created today and again you may
not get the results every day but if you
show up every day your life will look
different a problem you have for most
people is not the lack of ideas a lack
of vision it's the lack of consistently
showing up and so [ __ ] wish one thing
upon you that would be it I got a bounce
thank you guys so much the love I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon